the classrooms of yamutu Junior High
School stand empty for years more
students have left here than enrolled
after seven decades of operating the
small Village School in Japan's
Fukushima prefecture is preparing to
close its doors for good
when I first heard from the principal
that the school was closing down it was
sad but I also thought it was such a
waste to close the school with a long
history like this one
it's a nationwide phenomenal the
government says nine thousand schools
have shut down between 2002 and 2020 as
birth rates continue to decline the cost
of Education child care and the child
raising burden on women are cited as
some of the main causes last year annual
birth dropped below 800 000 for the
first time eight years earlier than
projected
this is here from the period when the
school had the most pupils there were
about 160 of them
are the last two students who will ever
graduate from the school
I don't know if there will be any
children left in the village by the time
I'm a nursery school teacher but if
there are I want to come back and teach
here the government has prioritized
boosting birth rates promising to double
the budget for child-related policies
and programs
for this small village it may already be
too late the question remains whether
Japan as a whole still has time to
reverse its demographic decline
Al Jazeera